so good afternoon I'm Jonathan that's
Patrick over there and we're going to
present some work that appeared just
this week in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences and our
work is an attempt to understand as the
title suggests the privacy properties of
telephone metadata so let me start with
some preparatory comments the first one
please ask questions feel free to just
raise your hand and ask at any point
it's a lot of material to move through
and it kind of changes between subjects
fairly quickly and so by all means jump
in a second the sort of obligatory
disclaimer that we speak only for
ourselves we don't speak on behalf of
any institutions the next one the law
specific obligatory disclaimer that no
no this is legal advice and then last
the government specific disclaimer well
i'm currently detailed over to the FCC I
don't speak on behalf of the FCC this is
just my stanford research ok so that's
kind of the stuff to get out of the way
now into the substance so i want to give
a quick roadmap of where we're going
first I want to talk through the status
of metadata under federal law how the
law regulates access to metadata then I
want to talk about the NSA's domestic
metadata programs and how the NSA
collected made metadata and analyzed it
for counterterrorism and other purposes
then I'm going to hand it off to Patrick
who's going to talk about how we
designed our study of telephone metadata
then what we learned about the graph
structure of telephone metadata which
has significant implications for the
NSA's programs then he's going to talk
about re identifying metadata so this
classic question of is it anonymous or
not what we found out about that then
last some discussion of inferences that
we were able to draw about individuals
in our study just using their metadata
so let me start with the status of
metadata under federal law and the first
thing to recognize is that there are a
bunch of possible definitions about
metadata there isn't just kind of one
overall definition of metadata in
federal law and the specific
constitutional provision or statute can
actually say or be interpreted to say
one of a range of things so some of the
definitions of metadata are colloquial
so sometimes courts or policy makers or
folks discussing surveillance programs
with the subscribe it as data about data
or the fact of a communication or
whatever is analogous to an envelope now
the outside of an envelope and classic
male sometimes metadata is defined with
respect to how it's used in a business
so for instance metadata is the set of
routine records retained by a business
that's the definition sometimes the
definition is based in engineering so
it's kind of technical standards define
what's metadata or what isn't metadata
yeah understood the word and legal
documents the the term is sometimes used
in court opinions and it is sometimes
used to describe the scope of the Fourth
Amendment's treatment of this area um
the word metadata I don't believe
appears in any federal surveillance
statute or um it certainly doesn't
appear in the Fourth Amendment and that
doesn't kind of have language ah
specific to this in fact that's a great
segue into the last possible range of
definitions and what what the law says
when it does specifically define the
category some statutes define metadata
is non content which is kind of not the
most useful definition it's like what
kind of by exception but not what the
exception is some statue talk about
dialing routing addressing and signaling
information whatever that means some
statutes list specific categories of
information so I'll say like name
address times and dates of
communications and then last of the
standard that's a kind of best known for
being adopted by the courts under the
Fourth Amendment it's information that's
knowingly divulged to a third party
sometimes called the third party
doctrine under the Fourth Amendment the
rationale is you knowingly give the
phone company phone numbers you
knowingly give your email provide
is the two addresses that you sent to
and you're from address so so that's
sort of a last legal definition is
another question yeah I've considered
metadata work SQL called metadata which
is very different from what you see here
major data to be ah so yes important
important clear talking about
communications metadata here file
metadata kind of a related but certainly
different thing and that too is raises
tricky legal questions because while we
focused on government access to
communications of course the government
sometimes does want access to stored
files and so there are questions of what
about the stored files can the
government obtained with a warrant and
what does the government can the
government obtained with lesser legal
process and it raises very similar
questions okay so some good news about
metadata so for all the convoluted
definitions that can point in opposite
directions for real-time
person-to-person communications the
definitions point in the same direction
so let me very clear about what I mean
by that so for communications like sorry
um we go phone calls text messages
emails I message that sort of thing the
definitions tend to point in the same
director directions the parties to the
communication the direction of the
communication who called whom who texted
him what time the communication was how
long they talked or how many characters
were in the communication so in many
contexts these definitions do kind of
match up reasonably well but that's not
always the case okay so let me give a
concrete example in the telephone a
context of what we're talking about with
metadata so it can include subscriber
information so if you've seen Blues
Brothers that Wrigley field's at 1060
west addison it's a great fake address
ok and then includes kind of individual
records like the number that was dialed
the direction of the call the time the
duration so something like that which in
that's actually out of my phone logs and
kind of that was Chinese takeout lunch
and there are different names for these
records there's sometimes called call
detail records or CDRs they sometimes
called local usage details for local
phone calls or Lud's if you ever seen an
old episode of law and order and they
say like pull the Lud's what they're
talking about is this information it's
like this called dialed number
recognition or DNR so for our purposes
essentially the same telephone metadata
okay another point to note about
metadata just to complicate the legal
picture even further is that the
competing definitions of metadata can
result in multiple layers of metadata
for a single communication so let me be
clear about how that works so let's
suppose Alice wants to send an email
through her email provider and let's
call that email Co Alice will login to
her email company and that's going to
generate some session metadata about
when Alice logged in what her IP address
was how long she stayed active when
connected to the email service that sort
of thing then if you go ahead and send
an email right that you know goes over
to the email service it might sit there
for a little while then eventually you
know the draft will get sent and bounced
off to its recipient and that's going to
generate some message metadata right so
two kinds of metadata one about how
you're using the email service another
one about individual messages sent over
that service and it turns out the law
actually treats those kinds of metadata
differently there are different legal
standards for getting those two types of
metadata ok so there's one wrinkle
another wrinkle is that the definitions
of metadata can point in opposite
directions and so I want to give a few
challenging fact patterns to round out
the legal discussion of places where
these definitions really have perplexed
the courts and folks trying to revise
surveillance law so let me give you
three examples the first communications
that aren't person to person so a
person's talking to a business web
browsing is a great example of that and
a questions really perplex the courts is
what part of a URL is metadata and what
part of a URL is content
and there's kind of general agreement
that a search query stuff off to the
right there in this particular URL at an
example of searching for a Stanford map
that's going to constitute content and
there's great agreement among the courts
that this information to left the
hostname you're communicating with
that's metadata but the stuff in the
middle who knows but kind of depends on
who you ask and so courts of actually
tried to parties apart like technology
standards for like how URLs are formed
to figure out like are these things
metadata or not or what are folks know
about this or what proportion of URLs
will have information like that so we're
just a treat assume that the rest of
this is going to be a content to it's a
total mess in some so okay so there's
one challenging place for the metadata
content definition where the law is just
totally unsettled another place where
the law is finally settled but took a
long place to get settled is stored
communications so webmail is a good
example gmail of course being very
popular provider and the issue here is
you knowingly give your email to Gmail
and so like in a sense that definition
of metadata applies even to the body of
the emails you store and it wasn't in
fact until 2010 that the courts clearly
recognized that the doctrines around
metadata don't apply to the to the to
the bodies of email you save with your
email provider so and in fact Congress
still hasn't fixed this problem so the
statute that says you can get the body
of an email without going through the
whole warrant process under certain
circumstances still is on the books it's
just probably unconstitutional according
to the courts okay so another
challenging example for definitions a
last challenging a definitional area is
location information so sometimes
location information is explicit like
the cell towers you're connected to some
courts consider that metadata under the
Constitution some don't there can also
be implicit locations like an IP address
or in the phone system a trunk
identifier can say a lot about where you
are and whether that constitutes
metadata for statutory constitutional
purposes very tricky too and in fact
that information can be really precise
so like so for example at one point I
pulled my IP edge
from my office upstairs and by using a
public look up information you could
figure out not just it's a Stanford IP
address not just it's the gates computer
science building but you could actually
figure out which floor in which wing and
so very very precise location
information even though that's not kind
of any sort of explicit giveaway of
location information okay so there's the
total mess that is defining metadata let
me get to the punch line of what it
means once information is defined to be
metadata and that is in general if a
court concludes that certain information
is metadata for constitutional and
statutory purposes first off there's no
constitutional protection so if if data
falls into the so-called third party
doctrine it's just not protected by the
Fourth Amendment so there goes one
source of privacy production and in
general there's very little statutory
privacy protection so Congress can enact
privacy safeguards beyond the
Constitution but in general it hasn't
gone very far in categories of
information that are considered to be
metadata so that's the punchline for
legal protections and to be very precise
about the legal procedures that are
available for obtaining this information
here's the kind of full grid so it
depends on whether law enforcement
agencies are investigating a crime or
national security agency is
investigating a potential national
national security threat or espionage so
on it matters whether the information is
stored or whether the surveillance is
prospective and in fact it also matters
in some circumstances what the medium of
the communication is it turns out that
in general internet communications get a
little bit more protection than phone
communications when there's a when the
records are stored and so this is the
full grid and I want to highlight two
particular orders on this grid because
they're the types of orders that came up
in the NSA program I'm going to get to
shortly the first is the business record
order or BR order you may have heard
about that in the news is section 215 of
the USA PATRIOT Act and that's an order
that allows obtaining stored metadata
for national security purposes
and the NSA used it to obtain telephone
metadata so it's listed as internet
there because you need to use one of
those in general to get internet
metadata but you can also get phone
metadata with it and then I also want to
highlight pen trap orders under the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act so
that's another type of order the NSA
used for metadata surveillance on a
prospective basis and the the NSA use
that for email metadata collection and
the standard for both of those is not
probable cause like you maybe may kind
of have heard colloquially that's the
standard for a warrant it sits lower and
so the statutory standard for for both
is actually relevant there's a much
lower standard the kind of hierarchy of
standard is relevance than reasonable
articulable suspicion than probable
cause and so it's kind of the lowest
level the NSA and FBI kind of
reinterpreted the business records
provisions the standard wound up being a
little bit higher than that but at least
as a statutory matter relevance okay so
that's kind of the full lay of the land
of metadata and federal law which is the
sort of legal backdrop that all of this
takes place against any questions on
that before moving on to the NSA's
programs addy order is named after 18
USC Section 2703 d D order and it's a
statutory creature that's sort of like a
mini warrant so you have to go to a
court and a court determines there's
reasonable articulable suspicion so that
the intermediate standard less than
probable cause but above relevance and
then that's sufficient to get internet
communications metadata that's stored so
concrete example some criminals using
Gmail and the FBI wants to obtain to and
from addresses times dates of
communication lengths of at of
communications they can go get a D order
one of these mini warrants without a
full showing of probable cause in
practice it appears that d orders aren't
used aren't used as much as one might
think so subpoenas are used ton for
phone records for instance d orders
actually not use nearly as much and the
sort of conventional wisdom in the
surveillance law academic community is
it by the time you're
up here is the statement of facts that
gives rise for me believing there's
reasonable articulable suspicion you're
presenting that to a judge you probably
already have probable cause anyway so in
practice d orders actually don't get
used quite as much as one might expect
but anyway in short that's what the
orders are okay metadata for statutory
purposes or um I believe the proposed UK
surveillance reform legislation recently
proposed legislation actually did pretty
clearly define uh how it would look at
internet traffic web traffic
specifically and it would consider host
names to be eligible for surveillance
under a lesser standard and then full
content of communications under a higher
standard but I think US law has some
things like that too so for instance in
the National Security Letter statute
section 27 09 actually spells out here's
what exactly you can get with a national
security letter or the subpoena
Authority for phone records comes from a
statute that says specifically here's
what you can get in the case of phone
metadata yeah I can't Swiss slow Swiss
law does not tell me what is data and
what is meta data at all Swiss law says
what you can do with what you can't do
how you name it is not something the
lawyers skin influence so I want to be
very clear that this is sort of
synthesizing the law in this area very
often legal opinions do use the term
metadata but the statutes are written in
terms that aren't that magic word they
do generally describe what law
enforcement can and can't do so this is
kind of backing out of that definitions
okay so that's the status of metadata
under federal law now let me get to the
NSA's domestic metadata programs and
then headed over to Patrick to work
through our study so okay I
want to emphasize that these are
domestic metadata programs at the NSA
has been reported to kind of have many
other programs outside the US are going
to focus today on programs that are
domestic and programs that have been
Declassified so the first program I want
to explain is the the earliest of the
data surveillance programs by the NSA
and that was looking at email metadata
it ran from 2001 to 2011 whose then shut
down the FISA Court approved it that's a
court that oversees FISA orders in 2004
and here is the idea for that program so
let's suppose Alice and Bob are
communicating via email and Alice is
sending emails to Bob Alice might use
webmail so there's HTTP might use smtp
for sending mail and bob might get his
email by webmail HTTP or pop or imap and
then between email servers smtp is used
to transfer messages and generally
there's encryption and authentication
between a person and their webmail
service or email service regardless
whether it's webmail and so there's a
lock there and there's a lock there but
for quite some time it turns out there
wasn't actually great encryption and
authentication of between email services
and so the NSA operated a program where
they would observe traffic flowing over
a connection points in the internet
backbone identify and extract metadata
and then store that for surveillance
purposes so that's kind of the early
metadata program the other program
operated for collecting metadata in bulk
approved later by the FISC was her phone
records is where we focused our study on
that program began 2001 continues to the
present hasn't been shut down has been
significantly modified and we explain
how that is and again was approved by
the fisc in 2006 so here's the structure
of this program and to note the legal
constraints on this pretty similar to
the legal constraints on the email
metadata program
okay so the structure was a government
official would present to a judge of the
FISA Court a targeting procedure on a
regular basis and the court would hand
back a business record order one order
approving not just surveillance of an
individual or a set of individuals but
rather that targeting procedure okay so
kind of very different from the
conventional surveillance model of of
having a one-off kind of order approved
like a warrant then the the government
would go to a telecommunications company
and present that business record order
and the company will respond with bulk
telephone metadata on an ongoing basis
so that's kind of the legal vehicles
used here let me get to the operational
details so fully metadata flowed in from
phone companies into a database of raw
data and it went back about five years
at the same time the NSA's analysts
would select identifiers phone numbers
or other kind of phone identifiers they
thought were associated with terrorist
activity and they had reasonable
articulable suspicion to believe that
that was associated terrorist activity
they'd store that those targeting
identifiers selectors being the term in
a database called the station table why
it was called that beats me the like
terminology for this is kind of
idiosyncratic the NSA would then combine
the query identifiers in the station
table with the raw data and go out two
to three hops within the data if we can
get to what the hops meant and what
those implications were in a little bit
and the resulting data was eligible for
an analyst to inspect that went to a
separate kind of category of data stored
in database called the corporate store
again why it was called that beats me
and individual analysts could and
analyze that on an ongoing basis and if
they found something of relevance to
national security they could distribute
the information so there's sort of the
full flow of information coming in from
the telecoms targeting and information
coming in from intelligence and then
intelligence products coming out the
other side
it was a reasonable articulated
suspicion a wine analyst would present
the case for their being Ras but then a
supervisor would have to make the
determination that's correct and we're
I'm gonna get to in a moment how that's
changed so that is no longer the case
yes this is operational programme not a
research program correct yes yes Elvis
looking around on the upper right there
that's a different set of analyst rather
than the one who started this I eat I it
certainly didn't need to be the exact
same analyst whether the analyst on the
right had to be qualified for using data
within this program I believe they did
have to have similar qualifications
internal training around this program
the question is more when Dad guys found
one way he for one suspicion that
committee be visible to somebody who's
investigating some other activity that
is an excellent question that I'm going
to get to in just a moment yes was is a
stereogram meant to be a tulip method
the efficiency thing or a secrecy being
candy analysts look at the raw data if
he finds it I animals should not be able
to look at the raw data the idea was
that only are qualified NSA technicians
who are cleaning the data making sure it
didn't include fields it shouldn't
include I would look at that raw data
you the fight see even the secret FISA
law according to Declassified FISA Court
opinions individual NSA analysts were
not permitted under court orders to look
at that data yeah okay so now to the
question of what were the kind of ways
in which the data could be used in
various parts of this this flowchart
great question and in fact one of the
very phenomena we wanted to study so
over here as I noted is it was
counterterrorism purposes right the the
RAS had to in fact be associated with
one of a specific asset of terrorist
organizations so very limited universe
but over here from the corporate store
in fact information could be used for
any foreign intelligence purpose and so
that creates a sort of unfortunate
dynamic where potentially information by
I did initially be identified over here
for counterterrorism purposes and over
here might get used for foreign
intelligence purposes kind of not
necessarily inherently troubling but of
course if a lot of information could be
obtained over here and used over here it
might create incentive to obtain a lot
of information over here so one of the
very phenomenon to study and Patricks
going to talk about how much data in
fact might be eligible by virtue of
having just one or small number of query
numbers over on the counterterrorism
side yeah the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance cool improving domestic
collection that ends up being used for
foreign intelligence so to be very clear
about the scope of the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act it is
actually primarily it primarily deals
with domestic activities so foreign
intelligence in the title of the act
relating to the purposes of the
surveillance is gathering foreign
intelligence information not that is
intelligence collected on foreign soil
in fact in general intelligence collect
on foreign soil isn't governed by
statute it tends to be governed by an
executive order I have a blog post from
some time ago about that if you'd like
to see the full flow chart it totally
depends on where the collection is and
what the medium of the communication is
and what the status of the various
parties are it gets very complicated in
short okay so now let me note what
happened to the law relatively recently
the USA Freedom Act which changed the
structure of the program and added some
privacy protections I'm gonna highlight
a few of them a kind of going from the
top left the raw data is no longer held
by the NSA it's now held by phone
companies and held for 18 months which
is the period provided for by federal
telecommunications regulation so the
idea is to take advantage of phone
records the phone companies hold anyway
and
leave the information with the phone
companies on the raw data side over here
there's now fisa court supervision of
targeting so it's no longer just an NSA
supervisor it's actually a judge of the
FISA Court the determines whether
targeting information is associated with
a terrorist organization with reasonable
articulable suspicion and then that two
to three hops constraint how far you can
look out in the metadata again Patrick's
can get into that in some detail that
got taken down to just two hops so those
are a core privacy protections for this
program implemented in the USA Freedom
Act so we pause there any questions on
the structure of the NSA's programs and
either for email or phone yeah going
back what's the washing um there
definitely was fisa court action on that
issue I'll readily admit I don't recall
what the outcome of it was yeah okay so
that's what I wanted to say about the
NSA's programs now let me hand it over
to Patrick to talk about the study we
conducted great thank you very much I
forgot a microphone I'm doing good so
with all that background on the research
that we wanted to do was sort of
understanding exactly what the
technological limitations are on these
NSA programs given the law that we
currently know so first are we talking
about how we perform this study and then
we'll go into some results that we found
okay so we're going to study telephone
metadata in order to do this we need to
have a database of telephone metadata so
the question is how are we going to get
enough telephone metadata that we can
and analyze it much like the NSA might
maybe learn something dishing things
well it turns out if you go and try to
ask the telecoms just give you a bunch
of telephone metadata they aren't super
happy to just dump one of these
databases for you so we had to find a
different solution and what we did
instead was we're going to build a
mobile app and this app can be
distributed to volunteers all over the
country and they be able to volunteer
their telephone metadata to us and we
would be able to build a database that
we could analyze and see what we can
learn so we
this app it's called meta phone it was
available on the android app store for
about nine months and volunteers from
all over the country we have all hears
from about 45 different states
washington DC and puerto rico we're able
to download this app and volunteer that
metadata to us in total we had about 800
participants so here's just a little
brief walkthrough of what it looked like
to use the app we have some you know
information disclosure and legal
notifications we asked people to log
into Facebook which we're going to use
for ground truth information for
inferences later and we give them some
information about you know how their
metadata might expose them to analysis
then they're done it's just loved one
off upload we don't sort of have any
sort of continuous collection we just
get the historical call logs from these
individuals specifically telephone
matter that we collect is win phone
calls were made who the phone call was
made to whether the phone call was
outgoing or incoming and how long the
phone call lasted we also collect
similar data for text messages this
comes out to about 250,000 individual
phone calls and about 1.2 million text
messages from our 800 participants so
there's a small drawback to this
approach of getting volunteers to you
know give them metadata to us and then
it's not a representative sample right
people who participate in this program
are likely to be more technologically
aware or privacy sensitive maybe they
found our study through tech blogs and
being on these there are also facebook
users they're also Android users so all
these things can kind of bias our sample
both parties of a phone call before you
can get your data no we just we just
need the permission of the individual
who's we're taking the data from the log
yeah so it's just the telephone metadata
it's not we're not taking any like your
phone doesn't store or we didn't have
access to like the contents with these
sorts of things but a few just examples
of how our database is not really
representative or volunteers and our
representative so they skew young we can
see here that sort of young people
vastly outnumber people who are sort of
middle age or older in our database it
also skews heavily male so
more than ninety percent of our
participants or about ninety percent of
our participants or men yeah so it's
making it a little bit more difficult to
generalize but the results were going to
find we think are broad enough that
these sorts of selection bias ease
aren't going to be a big problem okay so
that was a bit about our study design
what we collected how we did it I'm
going to go next into this understanding
of the telephone graph structure and
this is going to be essential to
understanding the reach of the NSA
programs as they currently exist and we
can think about this kind of like the
six degrees of Kevin Bacon problem right
so lots of people in Hollywood are
connected to Kevin Bacon through this
fun little game where whenever you
participate in a movie with another
actor you become connected to that
person and there's degrees of this
connection where I act with Kevin Bacon
I'm one step away from Kevin Bacon
someone acts with me that person is now
to step swiping Kevin Bacon it turns out
that a large number of actors are within
6 degrees we're going to do a similar
thing but instead with telephone calls
specifically this is important for our
definition of what we call a hop this is
going to be important for understanding
the nsa's power here so here we have an
individual phone cup own subscriber on
the Left called a seed and he makes some
number of phone calls right in this case
he calls three different people and the
each of these people are one hop away
from our individual seed in the call
graph now each of those three people can
call additional people let's say they
each call three people now we have nine
people connected to our individual seed
in two hops each of our nine people that
are in two hops away from our individual
seed call three more people and now we
have 27 people connected to our
individual seed within three hops so as
you can see this sort of the number of
hops away from individual you can go
increases the number of people that can
be that are sort of within these numbers
now excuse me there's a poor way of
explaining it there are more people
within three hops of an individual than
within two hops considerably more so in
addition this also depends on how many
people you call right if we were to
remake this figure with now 10 phone
calls instead of three phone calls we're
going to see ten a hundred thousand
people away from one two and three hops
rather than 39 and 27 so if we're going
to limit the ability to investigate
telephone metadata based on a sort of
hop limit we're going to say I'm only
able to query information about people
if they're within a certain number of
hops of a suspected terror suspect then
we have to understand both the degree
the number of people that an individual
might call and also the effective this
two versus three hop boundary okay so
how do we know how many people how many
people individual might call we think it
might look something like a power-law
distribution right where some a large
number people call a small number of
individuals but there's you know a small
number of people that then you know call
more and more and more people well we
actually see something more like this
it's pretty close to a power law with a
couple changes there's sort of a large
peak around you know ten hundred
individual phone calls you might make
not a lot of people make zero phone
calls so there's actually not just a you
know monotonically decreasing function
here and there's this sort of hump in
the middle and then also there's this
large tail we're a couple individuals in
the call graph actually call a
tremendous number of people and it seems
a little strange right so like how would
an individual person call ten to the
seven different other people and the
reason what how this works is not
actually they're not actually
individuals they're going to be
businesses so this graph is taken from
our 800 or so participants and
importantly only two participants in our
study had made phone calls to one
another and this graph shows so each one
of these blue dots is a participant and
there is a little an edge between two
dots if there's a phone call between
them and what we can see is there these
massive hub nodes through major
businesses things like spam phone calls
right you and I maybe have never Munich
ated before in real life but we may have
received a phone call from the same spam
phone number this sort of is like a
primary function of spam right the whole
point is to send as many phone calls as
possible other good examples things like
if you receive tweets from Twitter via
text message all of those tweets are
coming from the same phone number so
there's lots of people that are gonna be
connected through these massive hub
nodes in our data set in fact despite
the fact that
all of our participants were basically
strangers with one another on average a
single individual is connected to thirty
percent of other individuals in our data
set through these massive hub notes and
what this does is it basically defeats
any of these it sort of makes this hop
limitation totally useless right so well
we might expect that having only two or
three hops away from individual would
really constrain it to their like social
group what actually ends up happening is
that you are connected to perhaps tens
or hundreds of millions of individuals
in the United States through two hops
through these massive hub notes so what
we'd like to do then is estimate exactly
what the reach of the NSA programs are
before and after the change from the USA
Freedom Act and sort of looking at
including these hub nodes or if we're
going to make a sort of assumption that
the NSA is doing the right thing and
removing these hub nodes ahead of time
so over here on the Left we have a
figure that describes the reach of the
NSA programs depending on how long the
collection period is for one two and
three hops so we can see that if you
only have one hop well you can collect
some small number of people two hops you
get more people three hops you get even
more people on the right though we have
taken into account these hub notes and
what this means is that if you don't
remove the hub nodes basically no matter
how long of a time period you collect
data for we end up with you know 10 20
100 million people being wrapped up in
one of these queries through these
massive hub notes and in particular if
we assume the changes made from the USA
Freedom Act that is 18 months of
collection and two hops and we also
assume the NSA filters out these like
massive hub nodes what we get is about
25,000 individuals can be queried from a
single seed node under these new rules
it was considerably higher before but
this is what we have today okay so
that's a little bit about the graph
structure and how it limits the NSA's
ability to access data I'd like to next
talk about the problem of Rhea denta
fication that is identifying the owners
of phone numbers we'll start with a bit
of a quote so it says you have my
telephone number counting with your
telephone number
there are no names in that database and
this quote was set by President Obama so
we'd like to understand what it means to
have no names in a database specifically
what we do is we have a big list of
telephone numbers how many of them can
we identify their owners for well we
have to sort of approaches that we did
in our paper the first here on the left
is we queried automated and publicly
public and free sources Google Places
Yelp and Facebook turns out you can like
type in a cell phone number in a
Facebook and if it's self a number of a
person with a Facebook profile you know
you'll get their profile google and yelp
of course have the same thing for
businesses we can hit about thirty two
percent of phone numbers in our data set
just in these sort of free and automated
sources we put it a little bit more
legwork and we actually bought a month
of this service called intelius which
basically does this exact thing but for
as a commercial service and we also did
some googling and we were able to hit
about eighty-two percent of phone
numbers so it appears to be that you
know in a totally free and automated
fashion you can do okay and you put a
little bit more work into it you can
actually identify a large number of
individuals both businesses and sort of
individual cell phone subscribers okay
so that's really how we can identify
who's owns the phone numbers last thing
I'll be talking about here is what
inferences can we make about a person
right we have some information about
them we may be know what businesses they
call what really can we learn about an
individual and this is really where the
sort of the core of this question about
you know how sensitive is telephone
metadata lies okay so another quote so
we have about again the telephone
metadata database it says all it is is
the number of pairs when those calls
took place how long it took place so
that's the database and again this is
from the president so what can we learn
from this database that suggests
telephone number pairs when the calls
took place and how long they lasted well
we can infer where you live seems
relatively intuitive you're more likely
to call businesses that sort of exists
around you right I don't call a pizza
place that's on the East Coast I call
pizza place that lives that novice unit
lives that is right down the street and
so what we can do is from the results of
our Rhea denta fication process plot all
the businesses
you called on a map sort of find a
cluster of businesses and take that as
an estimation of what you might live we
can do pretty good so given some sort of
distance tolerance to where you list
your location on facebook we can be you
know fifty sixty seventy eighty ninety
percent accurate on predicting someone's
home location so what city you live in I
mean also if you're dating someone so
you might think well maybe the way in
which you call or communicate with your
significant other is different in the
way you can hit with your other friends
maybe you call them at different times a
day or your calls last for longer or you
call them more frequently we can plug
this information into a machine learning
algorithm and so be able to spit out a
prediction about how likely it is you
are in a relationship so this you know
tart is a little bit esoteric don't
worry about it but what we'd sort of
like ideally if you could be correct all
the time is this curve would sort of be
in the very upper left of this of this
graph but sort of just guessing is this
dotted line so we're doing somewhere in
between perfect and guessing but with
reasonable accuracy we can predict you
know you're dating somebody just from
the telephone metadata once we predicted
whether or not you're dating someone we
have a sort of simple heuristic for
deciding who you might be dating turns
out the most effective one is just what
person you called the most raw number of
times we can predict what religion you
might be affiliated with turns out this
is relatively simple people who call
religious organizations tend to call
religious organizations that correspond
to their religious affiliation so this
is right about three-quarters of the
time you find people in our data set
I've called some sort of you know a
church or whatever and like you know
reasonable accuracy that's the religious
affiliation okay so can we do even
better this is sort of some broad ideas
what can we specifically learn about a
person from their phone calls if we look
a little bit deeper so turns out if you
access the business records from google
places in yelp you don't just get the
name of business but you also get
information about the category of
business right so whether it's a pizza
shop whether it's a hospital whether
it's you know whatever so this chart
shows the percentage of participants in
our study that had at least one phone
call to a business of a certain category
this is all taken from google places and
yelp and we can see that
lots of people have called some sort of
you know health care provider we've got
legal services we've got you know
recruiting and draw placement I like
these two down at the bottom so people
that have called sort of adults
establishments or even marijuana
dispensaries maybe would real something
about you just from which businesses
that you called looking specifically at
health records or health services here
we can break that down further into
different subcategories of health
providers we see lots people call
dentists but we've got a couple other
really interesting ones things like you
know cardiology clinic or you know maybe
you've got you're going for substance
abuse treatment these sorts of things
might be particularly sensitive pieces
of medical information that you could
obtain just from these automated sources
you know google says hey look you've
called you know these medical service
providers that focus on this particular
kind of thing and this is all done in an
automated fashion but with a little bit
more legwork we can actually do much
better so I'm gonna give I'm gonna give
five I think pretty interesting
vignettes individuals in our in our
study that we thought we were able to
learn a particularly sensitive piece of
information about them so we have a
person in our data set who we believe
has ms just take we were to figure it
out just from the businesses that are
called we have a person our data set
that we believe actually the believe has
cardiac arrhythmia in fact we were able
to confirm this from publicly available
records that this person did indeed
doesn't he have a cardiac arrhythmia we
were able to make an accurate diagnosis
just from telephone metadata we have an
individual who purchased a particular
kind of firearm we were able to confirm
this one as well we've got a person who
has some call patterns that might be
consistent with starting a marijuana
grow operation so this might be of
interest to law enforcement and last we
have a person who based on their call
metadata we believe was seeking an
abortion so these are all things that I
think everyone would agree are sensitive
information on that we could obtain at
least you know an indication the sort of
thing is going on just from telephone
metadata so this this kind of concept
that there's a distinction between
content and metadata in terms of what
you can learn about someone really isn't
born in the facts okay so that's our
discussion of
and I sir just to wrap up here two major
takeaways that I want you to take from
this this talk the first is that it's
essential that public policy and in
particular privacy law is informed by
the relative irrelevant sciences right
so we had even a law passed the USA
Freedom Act that was supposed to
restrict the behavior of the NSA but it
was sort of passed based on intuition we
didn't have any actual scientific data
to back up really how effective these
changes were when we went from five
years to 18 months and within three hops
to two hops what really is the reach of
the NSA program we didn't have the right
data and so it's essential that public
policy is informed by good science and
the second is that we really should be
involving computer scientist in the
policy-making process so it's just it's
one thing to be able to have publicly
available science that you could you
know go and access and you know
activists can look to but it's quite
another thing to have you know
policymakers actually listen so we have
to get experts and scientists involved
in the policy-making process if we are
to produce hello policy that sort of
accurately reflects accurately reflects
the wishes of the public and with that I
think we're done with the main section
of the talk and we can go into a Q&A ah
weeks ago but if he was here and there I
had a chance ask him if he thought the
United States as a question of security
was in a crusade the capital C or sort
of culture war and its wits opinion that
we are actually in the middle of a jihad
which what's your guys can wire with
what's our for you don't need for
security not quite i'm sure i understand
what youre you'd buy the terminology
what's your opinion the level of the
kind of security that communications the
American citizens need so i think the
sort of aim of the work was really to
avoid taking a position on what the
right outcome is you know how do you
strike the balance between privacy and
national secure
law enforcement investigations that is
like so clearly a really hard set of
policy problems and I don't think we
have any like special claim to knowing
how to answer those questions but our
claim is our kind of take away is in
figuring out how to answer that question
you need to make sure the policy debate
is informed by the right facts because
if you're going to strike the right
balance you have to actually know what
you're balancing and so that's where we
tried to come out on that yeah in the
previous adventure of this korea
famously / provided that the FTC would
set the standards for wiretapping and
the companies would then have to hold
those standards it looks not like now
with the current legislative proposal by
birth Weinstein but they instead of
using the FTC or proposing to use the
courts instead perhaps these secret
courts what are the trade-offs between
using the FTC and using the courts for
this purpose you probably can't answer
this and I don't have the expertise to
answer that one I don't think are you
able to talk about this or I so let me
kind of explain the law around it so the
current law on this is the FCC not the
FTA yeah yeahs has an authority under
the communications assistance for law
enforcement act or colio that enables
the agency to require certain
surveillance capabilities so a telephone
provider has to make metadata and
content available to law enforcement and
then there are certain technical
standards for facilitating making that
information available important to note
Kalia with a minor exception that's not
particularly relevant to the substance
of this talk but doesn't take a position
on the right legal standard for
obtaining information it clear was about
a kind of facilitating information given
that law enforcement is it already
entitled to that information
so it's sort of a facilitating statutory
scheme it doesn't set the level there is
a proposal of late that would add kind
of a another means of facilitating
government access to information that
would be kind of in tandem with Kalia to
note Kalia already is not the only means
of compelling assistance you may have
seen in the news uh relatively recently
the litigation between the FBI and Apple
so that had to do with the all writs Act
which for stored communications as a
means of compelling assistance there's
also some litigation about your and a
half ago ballpark made more than that
with a company called lavabit are
related to compelled assistance for
accessing email communications on a
prospective basis specifically metadata
and that had deal with who got to
control ssl keys and that would had a
statutory component so kind of take a
step back of the full map there's Kalia
there's the all writs act for stored
communications there's assistance for
prospective surveillance under X button
FISA and then there's potentially to see
this new direction so there are a bunch
of kind of directions for assistance of
it in the law and could be could be more
again what we focused on is kind of the
authority given that the government
already had a means of obtaining the
information this is asking for a bit of
against but I'm gonna try so that was
all communications record pulled from
total communications companies need some
work cell phone communications a lot
more you've got services that are
providing end-to-end communications in
voice and text that are all data so all
data going over the Internet if with
communications like that so like for
example using the skype or I message for
text and voice calls how much metadata
do you think or know is accessible
how much does that make that picture
even harder to determine assuming it
makes it harder at all good it's
generally available right I yeah I'd I
think so i think this is mean that
information is you could you know
perhaps build you know a messaging
service that basically used VPNs and
things and tried to hide all of this
metadata but you know i don't think the
existence of something like imessage
versus text message which is sort of
being sent via internet or other
mechanisms is going to fundamentally
change the presence of this sort of
metadata the way in which you so see it
might be different but it's still air so
sorry how much did this cost and where
who financed to how many man years book
the right ballpark on this so i think we
paid 1995 for a month of intelius which
I think we used for like a day or
something like that I don't even know
and then we spent like two hours on
Google like googling some phone numbers
so it's just the two of us there's no
there was no fancy equipment I mean it's
all this compared to a sponsored project
oh yes we're both you know funded by
Stanford University in order to do
research but we didn't need to purchase
special equipment most of the machine
learning algorithms that we use in this
study are sort of pretty rudimentary as
a matter of fact so we didn't need you
know we could do all this in our office
when did this a lot more to editing the
paper yeah yeah under owning laws
preventing my phone company from so
environment or data to anyone who wants
to buy it so again I'm kind of in the
mode of describing the state of the law
without expressing an opinion on it
there is a set of rules enacted by the
FCC that protects your telephone records
telephone records as compared to 5p
burgers that that's correct and in fact
um there is
I can describe him not expressing an
opinion there is a current proposed rule
from the FCC that would impose similar
protections for isp records so IP
addresses and potentially much more than
that in the packet inspection uh so the
the FCC's proposal seeks comment on that
one important thing to note about deep
packet inspection that's where an ISP
looks in the contents of packets flowing
by so for instance looking the body of
the webpage or potentially looking at
the URL of a web page it's not entirely
clear whether urls will be considered
dpi or not that could implicate
wiretapping protections it's an open
legal question so kind of two bodies of
law and that there's what the FCC does
and there's also kind of federal and
state wiretapping protections if
participants have clawed made an
international call without it be
included in your announcement yes so all
of the we have basically all the phone
records that were stored you know in the
default Android little call logs you go
look at your past history ah yes we
didn't distinguish between international
and domestic calls in the way you can to
comment on life at the FCC you said on
assignment or something what were you
assigned from or and yet so I'm kind of
on detail from Stanford to the FCC and
helping the agency out on technical
issues life in the government has been
educational yeah maybe happy to talk
more about that kind of after the main
part is is wrapped up yeah yeah give it
back you were next Oh Jeff since four
wives helicon companies were collecting
this data in the first place in so long
so there's a kind of clear legal answer
to it with respect to 18 months and that
is under FCC rules they required to
there was like an earlier period where
they're storing for five years the NSA
was started it for five years I got it
so they kind of stream into the NSA and
then the internet hang onto them got
your bases so it seems like a real
identity is the basis of most of the
influences the drawing about certain
most of the sources and the bottom of
the slides were manual real identity
ultimate about that's right are there
any other planks you might say so the
inference by the other base see needs to
be inference process wing in or what you
don't you do a we need to fir figuring
out who's who instead do some other
analysis on the clustering people
calling each other without looking for
they are they're really kind of another
scenes like that so I'll say two things
about this the first is that the
relationship inference is done totally
without any RIA denta fication so that's
just based on things like how long your
phone call lasted or you know whether
it's late at night this sort of thing
we're limited quite a lot in two ways
one we the sort of default call log
implementation and Android only goes
back five hundred phone calls so
basically we aren't able to collect
nearly as much data as the NSA would be
able to collect under the current rules
this kind of makes it more difficult for
us to do really interesting sort of
cluster you know type analysis or
whatever and also all the individuals in
our data set are strangers so we can't
do any of this sort of like you know you
might be like this because your friends
are like this because we don't have any
people who are friends with other people
in our data set if someone were to do
more research with sort of more
population scale data these will be
interesting places that could go I
believe that during the World War two
the Nets is it went into Holland and use
the knee call billing records to track
down the Jews recursively a transitive
closure and after World at the end of
World War 2 the we did their phone
system to fastidiously forget what calls
have been made and went over to a billy
a meter that
essentially ran as fast as the expense
of the call and and when it went and dry
your phone stopped and you put in more
money the phone system doesn't have to
remember things to serve I suppose
that's certainly true there's no
technical regains its it's a bound on
the laws that you might conceive of yes
I suppose you could have meant a law
which would force all know telecoms to
toss any data about calls as soon as
they were made that isn't the law as it
stands and sort of the goal here is to
evaluate the reach of the law as it
stands but you know from the graph we
showed earlier if you were to have you
see these like three lines that went up
based on how long the collection period
was you can imagine if your question
period is 0 days you don't get an awful
lot of information on the 18 months and
applicability of that um I assume the
active question do companies like
bondage for example fall under that as
well and related question is do
companies like sky fall under that
either completely or partially by which
I mean you can do a skype call from
skype client to an actual phone number
if you pay for it or you can do a skype
call from Scott line to another skype
client I don't know I don't know this
one ah I'm not certain of the Leal
answer on that I don't want me state it
so I don't yeah relationship
without it seems I can quickly verify
your assumptions with individual study
participants so I'm wondering how you
can control for some things you're
making you enough intense that you food
business we should be based on science
rather than to southern princess we get
off my sister for an hour every day it's
not my boyfriend it's a number or maybe
I'm quite a bit late at night because we
have different times up and I am so I
was also wondering how to sort of
control of your social said we're making
right so we have information from
people's facebook profiles you know in
facebook you might post you know whether
or not you're in relationship or not and
that's how we're able to evaluate the
effectiveness our prediction algorithms
it's a little bit loose because of
course what you post on facebook isn't
necessarily exactly what your
relationship status is and maybe you are
in a relationship but you have single
listed or something like that so we the
data is a little bit noisy but we're
able to do all of our training for
machine learning based off of the
facebook ground truth and then evaluated
on other participants who have also
posted their facebook information and it
turns out that these kinds of features
like when you make the phone call you
know how long a phone call last is
relatively predictive of Queen
relationship with but you're right they
might not work for every single
individual so what the follow-on
research do you think needs to be done
to investigate this holder anymore and
and as well how do you how would you
propose to inject for computer science
into the political process or change
some of the views of lawyers I think
I've been cable the first part of that
so certainly i'd like to see this time
with larger data sets it's a little bit
difficult to expand our methodology of
just distributing things to individuals
via an app because just reaching enough
you know concerned individuals is kind
of tricky some research has been done in
the past using corporate data sets sort
of data sets of metadata delivered via
that from the telecoms and if you had
something like that so a much larger
database and if you could figure out a
way to get better ground truth about the
individual subscribers I think you could
sort of reproduce this data this
analysis but maybe be even more precise
and that would be an interesting way of
looking at things
right now we sort of have a lower bound
on the effectiveness of the NSA
presumably they have greater you know
resources than the two of us do and so
if you could more accurately represent
the resources of the NSA you could sort
of get a better picture of what they're
capable of doing I think your thong a
second part of the question yeah so I
think there's long been a sort of divide
between computer scientists and
policymakers in government and a closing
that gap is very tricky you know kind of
a there are folks who devote their
entire careers to influencing government
policy of course for computer scientist
that's never going to be the top line of
what they try to do and so I think
there's an awful lot of work to do in
educating the computer science community
about how to interact effectively in DC
awful lot of work to do and
understanding just the legal principles
of programs like this I think there's
kind of a tendency to retreat Laura
policies sort of loosey-goosey subject
matter and very often it is but it it
kind of does there are definite answers
in many cases and understanding them is
necessary to kind of studying where the
law law and policy or could it go so I
think interacting better in DC
potentially serving in the government
that's what I'm trying to do and kind of
understanding where the government isn't
where its heads at kind of pretty
essential going forwards and there are
some kind of glimmers of hope a bunch of
academic institutions individual
researchers who are really sort of
making a name for themselves now in
their outreach to government
organization but you're probably not
familiar with for reasons I mentioned at
the end of this comment which brought to
be doing this it's the Congressional
Technology Assessment organization never
heard of it the office of Technology
Assessment exalted it necessarily son
Justin Alfond dead yes it has had zero
dollars in the bud and since
60 yes so and I once tried to lobby to
to get it back and even the Democrats
didn't want to fit my bike fine i'm not
sure i'd say that they were opposed to
having all right so so bye-bye web
history Rick Congress used to have an
organization dedicated to providing a
technical input that's certainly one
model advocacy organizations who've
gotten much more sophisticated in ceria
academic organizations have gotten much
more sophisticated and kind of linking
their law and policy to tech so they're
a bunch of workable models and
thankfully a very smart folks are trying
lots of them now which is great computer
science technology work is about the
point in this area yes National
Academies provides work in this area the
President's Council science and
technology advisors does work in this
area there's now for cyber security
issues specifically through the Commerce
Department and expert board the
administration selected so they're kind
of a range of different mechanisms again
well I think all the above are great
yes I think gonna do the rest health
record or do you want to sure take a
couple minutes of yeah yeah okay sounds
got it okay I'll see you thanks yeah you
okay hey
you